foreign
Ty has rules
decides where you belong
and what you're worth
but you
you can chart a new course
[Music]
and even when death seems a certainty
do not give up
on the shores of a new world
you awaken
more determined than ever
to carve a life of your choice
fighting under our own flag we will take
what's ours
foreign
Society may have rules
but today
you decide where you belong
at what you're worth
foreign
or die as pirates
lives upon or die is a pirate you best
believe it's the pirate's life for me my
name is Yusuf and welcome to the
worldwide gameplay reveal of skull and
bones and oh yes we do have a launch
date the game is coming November 8th
2022 and joining me today on the deck of
this gorgeous ship is world producer
Vanessa ciao hey Vanessa hey yourself hi
everyone and game director Ryan Bernard
hey Ryan how's it going Yusuf hello
everyone
Now Vanessa we just got our first look
at the new skull and bones and it looks
like things have changed quite a bit
well can you tell us about this new
Direction yes our team has been working
really hard and we are so proud to
present what you see in the game today
forget everything you know about the
traditional pirate fantasy skull and
bones is taking a darker grittier
approach with our new game direction we
wanted to reimagine what Pirates were
really like drawing inspiration from the
Indian Ocean during the Golden Age of
piracy so you start as a survivor of a
shipwreck right washed up on an unknown
mysterious exotic location this is a
world where everything and everyone
wants you did and for ordinary people
like you and me the only way to survive
is to become a pirate and once you've
chosen that life of piracy there's no
turning back oh there's no turning back
for me I've already chosen the life of
piracy what does that entail exactly
well the world of skull and bones is
ruthless you come face to face with its
many dangers from vicious hippos and
crocodile dolls to Violent storms pirate
Hunters powerful corporations and even
the Mutiny of your very own crew so
every time you set sail it's going to be
an unpredictable experience Mutiny okay
okay I'm making a note right now keep
the crew happy
but Ryan obviously a pirate is nothing
without their ship how do we go about
building our Fleet true well skull and
bones is an open world or more aptly
open sea pirate experience right so you
start the game you basically have
nothing you have our smallest ship which
we call the Dow a basic spear in order
to fend off this Wildlife that's coming
after you and really as you progress
you'll need to collect the things you
find in the world and gather them as you
do contracts for the Pirates you come
across doing that will grow your infamy
which will give you access to new
blueprints or designs and allow you to
craft new ships different weapons
different armors and that's how you
build your Fleet in the game Yusef So
eventually you'll be able to rule the
Seas
okay I like that building my fleet
ruling the Seas sign me up for that I
want that I want the Thundering cannons
sinking ships the whole nine yards but
you know between us can you give me The
Insider tips here how do I make sure I'm
the most feared pirate on the ocean oh
well I mean the the short answer is just
to get good at the game you said but I
mean but really uh seriously the naval
combat is at the core of Skull and Bones
pirate experience right and we aim to
have Best in Class Naval Combat so we
want it to be visceral fast-paced
rewarding and we do that part of the way
we do that is to offer the player a wide
variety of different weapon choices
which you unlock through infamy so
you've seen cannons for instance but we
also have Greek Fire we have explosive
mortars we have bombards that you can
lob onto the decks of the enemy players
and sink their ships and that'll allow
our players the creativity to combine
different weapon types different armor
types and different ship types to give
them the best chance of success while
they're out at Sea pirating so the Greek
fire that you just mentioned is actually
pretty cool so with leather armor you
know get it out on your brick well I
have to admit that I do get satisfaction
watching other ships burn oh wait that
sounds so cool I want to light other
ships on fire I don't how do I do that
okay so uh as our pyromaniac has
explained here the Greek Fire is one of
the weapons you have also the ship she
mentioned and the armor are things that
you will unlock through gaining infamy
in our progression system so of course
classically Pirates were all about their
name right you were nobody without your
name and our progression system is is
the same we call it infamy so as you
have success in the game and you
progress and your name is going to be
known throughout the Indian Ocean and
pirates from further and further away
are going to want to offer you more and
more dangerous jobs with bigger and
bigger payout which will give you access
to better rewards in the game so the
name of the game is raise your infamy
and you'll have better opportunities oh
okay so I'm imagining the road to infamy
is going to be tough and lonely but it
doesn't have to be right true so first
off I mean everything in scolar modes
can be played solo but at our core we
are a social game right with the the dev
team we look at everything through the
lens of Co-op we want to ensure that
things like taking on the big pirate
hunters or privateers or taking on a
fort in the game is more rewarding and
actually easier when you play with other
players right so we can say that really
the best way to play Skull and Bones is
With Friends
now here's the important question sure
can I team up with my friends and Hunt
other players yeah we can team up
against Ryan okay so this happens far
too much on our internal tests okay so
you can as a player choose to opt into a
PVP server in which case you will be
able to shoot another players sometimes
on our weekly test that happens far too
often to certain people uh with the team
trying to take them out with this vast
array of weapons but so I can say for
certainty that the best way to play is
to have players with you to to watch
your back you know I can't wait to get
in these PVP servers because I want to
hunt specifically you Ryan okay putting
a Target on your back right now I'm
expecting all applications to come help
me but Vanessa Ryan thank you so much
for joining us thank you and for
everyone watching at home you've heard
us talk about Skull and Bones it's now
time to show you Skull and Bones here's
the world premiere of our Gameplay
trailer
welcome to Skull and Bones our game
takes place during the Golden Age of
piracy and a world inspired by the
beautiful yet dangerous Indian Ocean
you'll start your journey as an outcast
whose goal is to become the most
infamous pirate to sail these
treacherous Waters
after surviving a shipwreck you begin
your adventure in Saint Anne one of the
pirate Dems in our world dens are
centers of pirate activity where you can
craft new ships and Equipment provision
for your Expeditions at Sea pick up
contracts and socialize with other
players
any pirate with their cell will tell you
that preparation is key to success
get ready for any challenges that come
your way by checking that your cargo is
stocked with items like food and
ammunition
once you're set it's time to head out
and explore
as a rookie pirate you'll only have
access to a small Dow but as you
progress you'll be able to craft
different ships each with their own
unique play style
at Sea you'll need to pay close
attention to the condition of your ship
and the morale of your crew your crew
are a pack of vicious Raiders and Rovers
who will Mutiny against you if not kept
well fed and happy
if your ship sinks you'll lose some
progress and respawn at the nearest
discovered Den or Outpost
the good news is that most of your cargo
will be recovered and you'll have the
opportunity to retrieve the rest from
the wreckage but you'd better be quick
as other players can also steal it
as a pirate Captain your reputation is
everything and our game tracks this
through infamy the higher you're in for
me the more opportunities you'll get one
of the many ways to grow your infamy is
to take up contracts these are deals
that you can make with other pirates in
the world contracts can have great
rewards if you're successful or costs if
you fail
you can also gain infamy by completing
other activities such as exploration
plundering treasure hunts investigations
Dynamic events and much more you can
undertake these either Solo or with
other players the world of skull and
bones is filled with riches and
resources that you'll be able to gather
as you explore
lagoons and rivers are teeming with
dangerous wildlife that you can hunt for
animal skins and meat
you'll also be able to harvest a variety
of raw materials such as ore and wood
that can be refined and used for
crafting
crafting is an essential activity for
you to progress as an Infamous pirate
obtain Blueprints and use your refined
resources to craft stronger ships
weapons and armors
[Music]
in Skull and Bones ships serve many
different purposes cargo ships are
slower but useful if you need to
transport large volumes of loot
navigation ships sail faster but have
less cargo space and lower Hull HP
Firepower ships have more gun ports
allowing you to deal higher damage but
are more challenging to maneuver
similarly you can craft a wide array of
unique weapons and armors from Greek
fires to Giant ballisti to rocket
launchers and mortars as well as
different armor types which have varying
strengths and weaknesses against
incoming attacks
with your new Fleet and growing Arsenal
create a Loadout based on your personal
play style to become a force of
Destruction
out in the open ocean opportunities and
threats are abundant use your Spyglass
to identify lucrative trade routes or
wealthy Merchant ships and assess your
praised cargo and Firepower
strategize a plan of attack based on
your opponent's defenses and take
advantage of their weak points to deal
more damage
sinking your foes from afar rewards you
with only a portion of their cargo as
some of it will be lost to the depths
getting in close to execute a boarding
maneuver will help maximize your gains
but beware you can turn from Predator to
prey in a heartbeat if you attract The
Unwanted attention of privateers the
merciless pirate Hunters that Patrol the
Seas
if you enjoy the thrill of the hunt you
can also seek out other players and
Reign Terror on them
such PVP battles are high-stakes
activities that can be rewarding if you
emerge Victorious
from your Spoils of battle personalize
your individual look with outfits that
command respect
you can also select from a multitude of
ship customization options to instill
fear in your enemies
foreign
With The Wind in your sails Journey to
the furthest reaches of the Indian Ocean
from the coast of Africa to the East
Indies
encounter extreme weather events like
violent storms and monstrous Road waves
keep your eyes peeled for outposts which
are safe spots where you'll be able to
dock your ship for a short rest from the
perilous Seas here you can trade with
traveling merchants and clandestine
Smugglers selling rare and illegal Goods
uncover buried bounties at outposts as
you decipher treasure maps obtained
through your voyages although all the
content and skull and bones can be done
solo you might enjoy ruling the Seas
with your friends while sailing you can
also easily invite other Pirates you
encounter to group up synergize your
different play Styles ships and weapons
to defeat deadlier enemies
as you grow stronger take on more
difficult challenges such as attacking
Forts and plundering settlements and if
you're bold enough engage in Dynamic
events like taking down heavily Laden
Merchant ships and their Fleet of
Warship escorts
now it's up to you to write your own
story remember there is no one path to
follow no one way to play the world of
skull and bones is yours to discover
okay that was a lot did you get it all
let's recap we got pirate dens crafting
customization Naval Combat tons of ships
and weapons infamy Co-op PVP world
events and so much more and that's not
it y'all here to give us a sneak peek of
what to expect from Skull and Bones post
launch is our game's Quest director
Terry Han hey Terry hello Yousef hello
everybody now Terry what can we expect
from Skull and Bones post launch well as
a live multiplayer game our team is
dedicated to deliver the best open world
pirate experience for our players
with the sky and Bones team we are
committed to provide fresh new content
not just in the coming months but for
many years to come
after release we'll have a lineup of new
content and these are all three for our
players these include in-game War events
ranging from bigger daily challenges
that you can take as a group two smaller
team events ships weapons furniture and
many more free content for all players I
love to hear that Terry tell me a little
bit more about these challenges so you
can expect to not just engage with the
local factions but also with big
corporations like the company Royale who
has really strong bombard weapons so you
really need to watch out for that aside
from that you also work with kingpins to
smuggle and steal valuable cargos or
even go on a raid with your friends to a
nearby settlement or Fort or even engage
with a dynamic events where you can
board Merchant ships stealing valuable
cargos along the trade routes okay it
sounds like there's a ton of content
coming post launch I can't wait to get
my hands on it Terry thank you so much
for joining us thank you Yousef and to
everyone watching don't go anywhere
there's still a ton of content coming in
our post show but before then we're
going to check in with our community
developer Alexi [ __ ] who's going to
introduce us to the official Community
live stream the deck
thank you Yousef and thank you so much
to all of you for being here with us
today
over the past few months we've been
working very closely with our community
to refine our game and as we get up to
launch we'll be doing more of this
we will have Hands-On opportunities in
the coming months so register your
interest at our website skull and
bonesgame.com
speaking of which The Insider program is
also in full swing if you like what you
saw today and want to help us go and
sign up all you have to do if you select
it is play the game regularly and if you
want share your feedback with us
last but not least today we're also
kicking off the deck our official
committee live stream we want to bring
the people behind the game direct to you
think streamers YouTubers role players
Community leaders meet and chat with our
developers our artists or producers
basically all the people who work their
magic on this game and can't wait to
hear from you that's happening right now
with Ryan as the first guest so stay
tuned and enjoy
hello again and welcome to the tech
today we are officially kicking off the
first of our community live streams with
a special episode during which will
showcase more of strain bones gameplay
Ryan and I will take you through a high
level contract and show you how the game
Mechanics Work once you've explored and
progressed through the game
we'll show you some of the ship
customization but also and more
importantly on good old plundering
one more thing before I let you all
Discover it keep in mind that the team
here is still working very hard on the
game so everything you see is very much
a work in progress and still subject to
change
now kick back enjoy yourselves and don't
forget to let us know what you think
hey Ryan how are you doing I'm doing
well Alexi how are you very good thank
you so what are we doing here what's
happening we are in telek panjara which
is the second pirate and that our
players will come across in Skull and
Bones
coming we are playing we are actually
playing Skull and Bones so
um we are going to take a contract one
of our quests if you will to go uh
basically help out the local faction
here the rampa against the the evil DMC
and we're going to uh plunder one of
their settlements
so I'm just rolling through the den here
full of different Pirates some other
players
I'm just gonna leave a bit okay and
I'm gonna go to the carpenter here and
you can see by his name that he's got a
contract available for me so I'm gonna
check it out
captain
so get down we can and this one's called
Stevens oil Opus and we're gonna take
that one
and that's going to send us to plunder
what I can do is oh we actually need to
group first so let's
let me
um
find you I'm right in front of you I
think I can just or you can do that I
was gonna do it through the uh here we
go
I'm faster than you
yes I got it okay we are now we are now
it's gonna show did you accept all right
did I press the there we go oh nice
playing is more fun with friends playing
it does it gives you a nice little
message you know it's more fun with
friends so I'm gonna share the the
contract so from our map here I could
see all my different contracts I only
have one right now but I'm gonna go
ahead and share that
with you
you should get it all right
cool so now I can uh I can see it on my
journal yes
and I see the destination marker on the
map
and I'm gonna go ahead and I'll mark it
for you so we're gonna we're gonna head
out across the bay
to uh a lumber yard settlement from for
the Dutch
so if you go now to the
end of the dock you can
pimp your ride you can set up your
ship with a lot of different
customization options
so I'll take the I think I'm set up for
the Brigantine which is uh one of our
medium navigation ships it's good for
support it's really fast and responsive
but I'll take that I think you're set up
with the Firepower the big boy right so
I've got the brig I think it's pretty
heavy yeah so
um I would check though check your cargo
to make sure you've got some ammunition
some food to feed your your crew and
yourself and uh oh I've got some attack
me too you know what that is it's very
good food I think it's a seafood dish
here in uh in Singapore in Malay yes uh
I have not I'm not big on Seafood I
haven't partake partaken
personally but I hear it's really good
and it's very good in the game for uh
uh keeping your crew happy
so I'm gonna just take a look at what
they've set me up with it looks like
I've got the flamethrower the Greek fire
on the front
I've got
um
some bombards some crushing bombards
nice
that'll work on both sides
should I have a red cells of white cells
what's easier for you to recognize me uh
red sails white sales you look like a
merchant and I might try to shoot you
all right let's go for it all right I'm
gonna switch to
uh let's see
explosive extended Rockets
three
I'll go ahead and sit still while you
get ready okay wait for you around did
you look at your armor I did you did I
have a wooden Armor All Over so I've got
cargo to give me enough space whoops
I've got
uh
uh I've got leather which is good
against fire on the side that's fine
I got Cargo in the back
and I got terracotta I'm going to switch
this up
a little metal on this side
so again you know depending on what you
know weapons they're coming at us with
the different uh armors we'll have
pluses and minus uh again that against
that
Furniture what do I got equipped
nice okay I got a repair kit bonus
I've got chip health
nice sales
okay so we have a we have a few of our
friends from our QA team who are playing
the game right now of course some of
them are right here on the one of the
most I think it's actually the smallest
ship in the game the door right the Dow
yes that's our kind of hunter-gatherer
ship yeah so he's busy like fishing
shocks basically hunting Wildlife nice
all right I'm heading out
I'm not stalling anymore
I can see where you are on the map you
are yeah I'm just waiting for you yeah
you're just I'm going out the other side
but I'll steer towards you oh I think I
see our little uh our little Hunter here
as well Captain wibbles taking out some
sharks
of course you you definitely don't want
to use the big ships on the Sharks
because you'll just blow them up and
there won't be any usable skins or uh
or meat which is definitely what you
want to do when you're hunting those
[Music]
all right I see you now all right I'm
gonna head across let's see do we Market
I think I mucked it already yeah it's
mucked already
all right I'm heading across as well
so we're going there to essentially just
get what like some jars of oil well
that's the contract the the Carpenters
there's our Mark the carpenter is really
looking for this uh jar jar of oil right
um but this will show off the plunder
mechanics so a lot of the settlements or
uh forts that you'll be able to attack
and engage in the game
um use whoa that was cool yeah wet shop
there's a lot of things use uh what we
call plundering so essentially your crew
goes ashore into the settlement they're
ravaging uh the goods and commodities
and they're filling up a barge which you
can then loot at any time and you can
leave and your job is to stay alive and
take out any maybe reinforcements that
come along or take out the towers along
that are set up to defend the settlement
um as you can see the Dutch here are
already with a couple towers and a
couple ships so on the way back we
probably need to be careful because I
think these are some of the other plays
doing some PVP over there what's that oh
they're PVP and over yeah I think you
pass right by them right I did I was
focused on talking about the uh the
plunder yeah I was just working getting
really close to them I'll wait till
you're in the area because you're you're
lag behind a little bit it
and you're you're my muscles so I need
you up here up close so probably what's
going to happen
because we're gonna we're gonna see
these all these nice little ships that
are calmly parked here are going to uh
all right I'm here are going to wake up
when I so I I can Spyglass the um
uh
the lumber yard here and I can see and
that'll give me the option or when I get
a little closer it'll give me the option
to start uh plunder
here we go
all right I'm gonna start it right it's
happening now my yeah did you get the
did it start for you okay yeah I'm gonna
see that plunder track across the top
uh which is Gonna Fill up as we're kind
of as our crew is stealing the booty and
now we're gonna see uh
potentially some reinforces coming
reinforcements come in I'm gonna take
out these towers first off yeah maybe
I'm the left Tower okay
oh and I get the green arrow up and that
tells me that I'm doing good damage
against the stone here with my explosive
mortars boom oh oh boy I'm gonna brace
see if I can burn this one nice side
incoming
incoming mortars my way but I'm bracing
the damage
we're okay we're okay which one are you
attacking there are merchants in front
are you checking out the ships okay I'll
try to take out this other Tower I think
I have bombards on this side as well
yeah yeah so the printer is actually a
short work of this guy
nice oh yeah
all right tower two is down
all right we got a lot we got a lot of
reinforcements coming in well
we'll turn around all right I'm gonna
help you with that guy yeah you almost
got him
I see it I see you I see you
can you board him do you want me to sink
him or yeah
all right well he's done yeah I got him
all right we're almost to our first loot
[Music]
but we gotta we got another player in
here maybe
I want to attack him
swabbing
nice
this one is very long
all right we got our first
their first
track point
you're still going at it over there
you should repair
okay I'm in the middle of the board oh
you're flooding as well oh my God yeah
boarding is quite dangerous if you do it
at the wrong time right
yes
that was actually you good thing I can't
do damage if you're in the red circles
uh you can reduce the damage
we're definitely getting a lot of
mortars out here
try to burn them a little bit
[Music]
oh I gotta get back in the plunder area
we definitely got to stay in close so
you can't kind of you know sail away
over the Thunder will will stop
you guys are hanging around the outside
what are you doing we'll take some take
some orders buddy
I'm sending some as well
look at that burn
but they're trying to drag us out of the
plunder roll I don't know this I think
some are uh reinforcements coming in and
some are Dutch that are in the area so
they're not all going to come in
that's part of it oh I got ready spray
sprays
I want to finish burning this one
I got I think I got out of the area
you didn't get back in time
no no I'm okay I meant I got out of the
uh the mortar area
oh we hit nice we got two yeah I think
we're doing good we are we're surviving
well we I cheated and took those
bombards against the towers took them
out really really quickly quite like the
combo of Motors to keep it away keep
them away and the moment they get close
that's why you turn around and use the
flamethrower
is that working well for you yeah it's
working very well I was like does it
doesn't matter what they fall close I
always have something yeah I'm just
living these racks that you're thinking
I can see that yes
[Applause]
just waiting we got two more tracks and
we finished the hole we get the the
maximum coinage
it looks like you took out all of the uh
reinforcements the last two are just
like nope I'm not going in I've seen the
others I've seen what happened to them
so they can't they can't draw us out all
right I'm gonna go over here and see
what's over here
I think maybe some of our uh some other
players are helping us out with some of
the reinforcements oh that's why it
could be
true oh oh okay we've got more uh
there's more coming yeah yeah
finally
oh yeah that's a lot though by yourself
it's quite it's a lot harder
okay we need to get okay this is serious
business
oh
okay there's like four or five coming in
right there I'm gonna go right in I'm
gonna go straight in send them on fire
right away okay
I'll try to I'll go long distance style
oh I don't have a I don't have an
auxiliary weapon equipped
okay it's okay
this one's done trying to board him I'm
too far away
oh I got it I think I got it yeah
nice
[Music]
completing challenges which is always
good
all right
oh
[ __ ] me out
I'm on the Rampage
are you just calling all of them I'm
burning them
yeah you think they set you up uh they
set you up a little thing so it is I'm
thinking on like three four ships at the
same time no that's that's that's what
happens when we uh
the dev testers hook you up with a with
a loadout
I mean
yes
you've earned all of this equipment
oh
a bit of boarding I was it was the wrong
weapon type but he's still sad oh I
think we finished maybe we finished okay
I'm gonna go loot
and
flame and smoking
it's a little celebration perfume
that's when we got our contract item
which is what we wanted
are you leaving the area taking the
Commodities so I can sell them
A Relic
where are you I'm gonna leave the rest
I'm just getting the uh the loot all
right so let's let's try to head back
across the uh yeah I'm just trying to
clear the Dead Man's straight you see
anyone is it safe I've got the I've got
the oil I don't want to lose it yes I
mean who's attacking you it's I don't
know where it's coming from but I think
it's this one over there that was really
cool it's long distance
I think it's these guys there oh oh
there's some DMC I think there's some
players in there though too yep you're
thanking us
he's fighting with us right not
attacking me someone's attacking you
yeah don't always coming I think it's
either it's explosive no it looks really
cool it's explosive mortars they're
coming from above
yeah you just just keep them off
Invincible just you're a decoy decoy no
no
yeah slayer was another player he was
boarding me for sure but I think he got
sunk by the
by the uh the Dutch behind him
almost there I've been covered no I'm
not in cupboard
there you go yes burn him keep him busy
oh it's a long range coming in
all right now once I get back to the gym
coming into a safe Zone
are you saying somebody nice
why are you so far already because I'm
in the Navigator I'm in the brilliant
team man
nobody's attacking you anymore no I'm
safe I'm gonna go turn it in
and yeah there's there's a lot the
megaforts down there but let me turn
this in so I'm gonna go
so are you still fighting are you done
fighting out there I'm done fighting now
okay
you should get this as well I don't know
we're in here in my group okay maybe
you're in combat yeah
uh
Dent protection I'm gonna wait for you
or try to come out I'm good I'm good
okay okay
we can remove our
um
our hostility
all right we both made it back alive we
did
we made it we got the contract done you
want to go look for some more trouble
should we go uh I'm just gonna repair my
ship okay you can do that here
and then yeah then I'm ready to go again
all right let's go should we go north
and see or did you say you knew uh I
want to go to like the most heated
region of
uh I think it's not real yeah I think
it's
I think it's uh but you know what maybe
the the players are attacking me just
now on my way back maybe they see his
maybe we can take revenge for us
okay you wanna you wanna go after that
okay I think there's something
interesting down there that's marked it
um
all right let's go look for these
players I mean it wasn't this guy this
is he's just in a little no it wasn't
these guys just in a little Dow it's
just seeing this guy just Captain
wibbles he's just out here hunting
sharks all day long what do you like to
do there they are
they could have once you once you kind
of uh how do I put this tactfully
retreated
um
we could have headed back let's go let's
go this way go towards my mark
can you play Shanti uh
um I think he's deep out down and then
yep
so you get music I don't I do it must be
because I'm the group leader
I'm the group cat I'm the group Captain
yeah they're mad at you
beautiful the weather is really nice
today so we don't have to deal with
storms that's good
kind of unusual and uh
this area I think I'm quite a bit faster
than you
you're way faster I feel very heavy yeah
are you in cupboard no I'm not okay
oh you know we there's there's a we need
to give a good reason to have the
different ship classes right so the
navigation ships are quite a bit faster
this is the fastest ship we have in the
game Brigantine right now oh okay I see
some stuff over here that looks uh
it looks like we could be
moving into uh some Dutch territory some
hostile territory which means that even
if they weren't already mad at us which
they aren't currently just be because
our hostility wore off because we paid
up somebody right too no I didn't
actually I didn't find them in telephone
jar we just headed back out
but it drops eventually right
um it doesn't take too long but if you
build it up too high you do have to pay
a fixer to to lower it so are we aiming
for that uh God Tower over there this is
the Dutch controlled Waters right so
normally you go in here uh well like us
like you know well-equipped group of
pirates
but if we get too close to any of the
settlements or the ships they're going
to uh engage us
and I think this is a fort in front of
us
some things to engage over here there's
four Towers right right it is
your compass will turn red to let you
know and the towers are like not happy
that I'm here no
so we'll see how long we last here
yeah of course where where are you if I
oh you went too close to the one on the
side okay I've got the ones in the front
here there's five of them
brace
so it's a I think uh we've moved into a
higher tier of enemies I'm gonna have
backup
someone coming I think other players are
following us and helping us nice nice oh
they're attacking me now I'm not nice
not nice I thought they were with us I'm
doing good damage
but I'm taking a lot of damage are you
coming over to attack these with me okay
look on your maps you can see me I'll be
the green chip
I'm right behind you okay so I'm trying
to take out these and I'm bringing those
two players back I can't tell if they're
with us or against us
well hopefully hopefully they're not
against us because we're taking oh my
gosh
we got some some explosive mortars
coming in race
yes just well it's just the outside of a
fort
oh
this one we're just destroying so I can
start actually I'll start the plunder
them I was trying to weaken them a
little bit before we started it what are
you doing
here we go here we go here we go so you
can see do you see how many Elite points
there are in this one that also lets you
know that it's more difficult there we
go there we go
I don't think it's gonna end well let's
see maybe these other players will come
join the plunder
the problem is you gotta you gotta the
challenge is you gotta get close
to I'm doing good bombard Grandma did
you have bombard cheese or bombards
um or mortars
but then you're open to their uh
their volleys praise
it's all about timing right finding the
right time to shoot
and then move yeah
and hope they're aiming at someone else
oh that was cool
oh
oh we got one
yeah it's on the other side there the
loot barge where our we was putting
down already oh yeah they're gonna be
putting reinforcements soon though yeah
that's one that's one that's when it's
here yeah YouTube they're right behind
you you keep I got the bombard do you
you take the reinforcements I'll take
the I'll try to take out the keep taking
out the towers
right I think I'm out of Greek oh damn
it oh you're out of your oil oh maybe I
I know I dumped mine for weight I dumped
mine at the other fumble you should have
picked it up it's okay it's okay all
right you have to use a different tactic
yes you have to use tactic number two
now we've only got
I think there's
one one Tower left over here
to get rid of these towers it's uh it's
gonna be a lot less dangerous we just
have to survive the the reinforcements
very good we can do this we can do this
all right
more than I have to go over here we
could also just Loot and leave no I'm
like I'm into this watch out
before they weren't mad before I didn't
know
is it almost down or no we're we're
halfway I think our our friendly depth
testers definitely helped us out yeah
for sure
it did it did take a look at what's
across the water here ooh very cool
another settlement we could do later
these are really heavy though yeah good
Lord that's what they're going through
I'm just taking two I don't even need
that oh but I'll take some whoops
so close
there it is
plunder complete yes can we get the
infamy big infamy you always end up
looting stuff
how do you do that well because I know I
know where to go I know where to go come
over come come to the barge it's nothing
it's about staying alive well we're four
or five
now we run now we run right now
we need to get out of the uh hostile
territory I'm gonna go North go I'm
gonna Market go towards that marker
oh
the weather's changed it's getting uh
it's definitely a fog rolled in maybe a
storm is coming
we're not in the open sea though so we
don't worry about roadways or any of
that kind of
one of our friendly QC or QA and Dev
testers has decided to come and uh
attack me as I'm trying to get away
killed the player I did well he came at
me like a madman he knows he got loot
exactly that area we were in is actually
just a tiny fraction of the whole thing
right yeah the the so the Romper and the
which is a local faction and the DMC are
at war in this whole area so some areas
uh the Dutch Merchant company controls
like hostile territory other areas are
kind of open or the rampant territory so
it's kind of piecemeal through here but
of course we like to help the rampa and
and and and because we at the underdog
and pirate the DMC exactly which is just
what we did so what are we doing next
are we heading back to I'm heading back
to telegram to try to stash some of this
stuff in the warehouse before we lose it
ooh nice nice beautiful kind of done
setting here in telegranjara
on our cheeky Dev testers that were
helping us out or and or attacking us
all right we made it we did
that was intense did you like that it
was pretty good it was pretty cool I
really I like the uh the circular
plunders are pretty great they're very
different when you go all the way around
but yeah we got we got lucky that we got
help I think I don't think we would have
survivors to us yeah so hopefully it's
uh that was exciting for everyone else
as it was for us
and uh we'll see you out there in the
Open Seas all right thanks a lot Ryan
and talk to you soon you too cheers and
with this this is the end of our show
today thank you so much once again for
being here and staying with us all the
way until the end we hope you like what
you saw and we can't wait to read all of
your comments so please go on the forums
go on with it or the social media of
your choice and let us know what you
liked or what you didn't like with your
help we hope to make current Bones the
best pirate game ever
we know some of you are really eager to
play the game and the team here is
working really hard to make this a
reality
we will have live phases happening soon
so please keep an eye on our official
channels so you can be the first one to
know when that happens
if you sign up for The Insider program
thank you once again for your
willingness to help us
we can't promise you'll make it but if
you are selected we'll be reaching out
to you by email so make sure you check
your mailbox regularly so you don't miss
out
finally this is only the beginning first
we intend to continue sharing more
information about screen buns through
future episodes of the deck such as this
one through official websites and of
course our social media channels
thank you once again for your support
and I'll see you next time bye